Okay, so the market has opened up this
morning
uh pre-market
and had a huge kind of move up here.
Uh both the Nasdaq and the ES have done
this. They've broken this previous
swing highs uh and overall, I mean,
looks like
you know, pretty bullish. Like it looks
like we're going to bottom here. Uh you
know, probably come up here and test
this. I don't know I don't know if it's
a huge bottom, but some kind of bottom
like to where the next day or two is
most likely to be overall bullish.
Uh so, going into a 5-minute chart of
this move from this morning,
uh you know, it kind of started like at
8:00 a.m. Eastern. So, it's like an hour
and a half before the market. Big move
up. Looking at this,
this is definitely like overextended
terrain to where, hey, this is a big
move that could reverse.
Will it reverse today? I don't know.
Um it's kind of hard with these moves
when the market's kind of breaking out
like it is cuz sometimes the breakouts,
uh you know, it might pull back here and
continue higher um because, you know,
overall, the market's kind of been
consolidating for a few days. And so, a
big move isn't necessarily as unhealthy
um as if it happened during um a trend
or uh a time where, you know, hadn't
really consolidated as much. So, Nasdaq
looks exactly the same. They've I was
watching the previous highs here.
They've clearly broken that. I was
trying to see if there was Well, is
there an upwards resistance line we
could sell off of? We broke that already
um for both of these markets. There was
kind of this one in the ES um that just
included these two. We've kind of broken
that, too.
Um
and so, you know, the market opened up
right here at 9:30 and we've kind of
just continued this. We haven't really
continued that much. We're kind of just
in a consolidation right here.
But we're holding this uptrend.
And
come 10:00
here Eastern time, we have news for 30
minutes after the open.
And you know, this would be a potential
timing to look for a reversal. Now, the
hard part is there's not really a good
resistance level to show off of. I mean,
granted technically there is this high.
Like if I pull this across and keep it
small,
um
just to see, you know, maybe that's
there's something there.
Uh
I can see that, you know, both markets
are kind of touching that.
And so maybe that's you know, that's
enough if this sets up uh well enough
with everything else, you know,
uh with in terms of of setting up like a
nice head and shoulders pattern. Uh you
know, maybe we do something like this.
I would consider doing that if it kind
of didn't act super choppy, but
it this is a lot of chop, which makes me
less inclined to enter.
Um
as well, looking at the day before,
this can kind of key into how the market
could act is market opened up here, kind
of just trended higher.
It looks really just
not good. I mean, like this this looks
pretty healthy in my eyes.
And then all of a sudden, it just kind
of fell out of bed. Those are not really
tradeable spots if you ask me, but it
did kind of give back the morning move.
Um
So, could happen here again, too, and it
could come up here, sell off here, and
then continue higher. Big picture, that
would make sense.
Um
you know, coming and testing this
previous high, basically.
And you can see here uh when market
opened it kind of
had a little bit of a pullback here too
even. So
that's something that
if we do get going we could break that
and continue lower
and I could see the first kind of line
of defense would be
coming down here. That would be kind of
the first easy target I would say.
And then the next one would be you know
somewhere down here.
So
that's
I don't even know if I'm going to short
though
but we are coming up on the 10:00
timing.
And so you know we are breaking this
potentially. It's not necessarily broken
yet I would say.
But
there's definitely potential.
So want to pay attention stay focused
because we could get a trade here in the
next couple of minutes.
And remembering that hey maybe I don't
like a couple of things
but I can't it's hard to ignore this big
picture move.
This move is definitely something that's
going to get reversed. I don't know if
it'll happen right now or could happen
later this afternoon or could happen
tomorrow.
So
you know got to remember that overall
big picture
you know at a 15 minute chart market's
volatile.
We're in just a volatile
back and forth where a lot of these big
moves are getting reversed very quickly
a lot of the time and some of them like
this one took a day or two to reverse.
I think if it's going to continue higher
this is where it does it.
In terms of a long spot this is what I'd
want to see.
I'd want to see it break this low
chop around a bit maybe make a higher
low.
And then continue higher and you'd get
long and you you'd continue the trend
up.
And I think if this
does that and it fails,
that's a solid reason to keep going
down, you know, we've kind of got a head
and shoulders here.
A
little bit more of a push higher, just a
tiny bit would I think would fit that
bill a lot better in that story a little
bit better.
The worst part here would be if it
double bottoms and I get in,
but
that is totally possible.
But I think I want to have my order here
ready because I think
the signal is good enough
to jump in short.
Okay, we are filled short. I like that
candlestick.
Um sometimes I would actually wait to
see how this
pulls back and maybe I should have in
this market um because it's been choppy
just to wait and then have a order right
here, but I think the signal's good
enough. I'm just going to let it do its
thing.
Yeah, so as we go down here, the market
opened pretty much at this price right
here. Uh so I mean this the the high
this zone is great for that. My limit
order here isn't in anywhere special,
it's just kind of down here.
Um I would love to get 3X, but again,
like we're just going to see how this
plays out. We could totally pull back
here, retest.
Um I could totally see us retesting this
low right here.
Uh in terms of just
a you know, we're kind of going in a
stair step pattern down, right? And so,
we could come up here, retest this, and
continue lower. That is totally healthy
um in a downtrend. And also,
Nasdaq is pretty much
um
hasn't quite given up this move, but
it's it's working on it, and it's
testing the previous highs.
Um same with the ES, and so uh this is
just a spot where
uh
the market could just bounce here um and
continue higher. Big big picture trend
could take over, and I could lose the
trade still. So, we're not out of the
woods yet in terms of uh there's not
enough information to move my stop down
yet. I would say if this does a little
pullback here um and prints a nice
candle like this, I will definitely move
to break even at that point. Um
because I think then if it if it does
this and and maybe does this, reverses,
I'll get out. Um
This is a nice clean acceleration. I
would expect some kind of pullback here,
but if it makes another leg down, that's
likely to be saying, "Okay, the trend is
really getting going."
Um and either it's going to continue, or
it's going to fail, and this is a uh
just a fake lower. And so, at that
point, I want to you know, take the risk
off the trade.
Cuz the entry is good, but I you know,
you never know um
how far this is going to pull back,
right? I The market's already pulled
back some. Um and I'm I'm looking for a
deeper pullback, but if the trend
continues higher,
um it could just bounce anywhere here
and continue up. So, that's kind of how
I like to think about managing it. Um
so, it it has done this kind of push
lower, like I just said, and so, I'm
going to go to break even.
Um and let my room know, uh and then
continue from there. Um
I think if it if it really starts to
accelerate here, I will go a previous
candlestick trailing stop.
Uh but again, we will see how it goes.
Also,
this downtrend at this point,
uh
I guess I would I would hold until then.
At this point, it could still hold, um
but
it's definitely accelerating in a really
nice way.
That's a huge candlestick. Usually,
those are a really good signal that the
market is starting to accelerate.
Um usually, if it breaks the high of
this candlestick, that's a bad signal.
Um and it will start to reverse.
Um I'm not going to move my stop down
yet, but I could move it down here.
Usually, it'll hold this and continue
lower. A pullback to here is totally
fine.
Um
it would really be a bummer if it does
that puke there and then reverses.
Again, the Nasdaq here is pretty much at
the open.
Um
kind of just need to
wait and see it how it plays out. I
don't really want to
um because this momentum, there is this
momentum potential.
If it does this, I want to try and stay
in. I think I'm just going to leave it
at break even cuz closing out here at 1x
uh versus letting the potential of 3+x
um close out, I think it's not worth the
risk. You know, the the risk reward is
still in my favor in terms of the
potential here.
Um
you know, I'm risking an essentially one
to make, I would say, two or three.
Uh that's This is not a good signal,
though,
that it it's done a big reversal like
this. Um
that's a big momentum switch.
And so, I think it's likely just pops up
and knocks me out, but
just trying to breathe through
the motions of wanting to do something
and just let it do its thing. You know,
I got to remember the 5-minute picture
looks good.
Um
it has given back a lot of this move if
you think about it really fast.
Um but the potential to pop up here and
fail and continue lower, I I think it's
50/50 that it goes either direction.
Um still. And so, keeping that in mind,
um
you know, I just got to let it do its
thing.
Man, this really sucks. That sucks to
have happened.
It looks like he's just going to knock
me out, you know,
I'm praying that it doesn't. It could,
but like uh it's it's trade's over.
That really sucks.
Um
to see it look really good, like it's
going to just
be a 3x trade pretty easily, and then
for it to just uh rip your head off.
Um but that's how trading goes. You
know, I'm I'm praying here that that's
that's the reversal that it had.
Um
Yeah.
I don't know, maybe it holds this
downtrend, and I'm just
got incredibly lucky, but at this point
my stop's in a great spot. If it's going
to continue lower, that's the spot, and
if it's going to push higher, that's the
spot I'd want to get out as well.
Overall,
I'm super happy I got in the trade. The
entry, I think, was perfect. Um
patiently waited. You know, I haven't
taken a trade in weeks. I've Granted
I've been gone and sick, but like
um getting back on the horse is hard
sometimes. And you know, entry is 95% of
your job. Managing it, you never know
what could happen. Um this thing could
have just puked and I could have been up
nine grand by now, or it could be doing
this.
Um but I moved my my stop loss when it
made sense. Um
you know, you can always you can always
hindsight and say, "Oh, I should have
just got out at 2x." Um but honestly, in
terms of following my strategy,
executed perfectly. So,
in that sense, I'm not upset about this
trade at all. Uh obviously, this
specific trade, it sucks
um that this is probably just going to
be break even.
And
you know, when it's it's could have been
what it could have been, but
that that's trading, you know, you
That's why That's why I like to not
trade that often because this is an
emotional roller coaster,
you know? I It was looked amazing for a
second, and then your hopes and dreams
got wiped away, and now it's like I'm
holding on by a thread that this could
push lower, but it's like
uh who knows, you know?
Um
like it could it could just come down
here
and reverse back higher. There There's
This is not out of the woods yet. I
think if we break this low,
then we're back in business. But until
then, uh this could easily just double
bottom here. And maybe I'll try and
sneak out, uh pull my stop down here,
you know, and maybe I'll get 500 bucks.
Uh which is still $500, but at the size
I'm trading, it's kind of nothing. You
know, it's just half of half half my
risk, you know? Um
which it it is nothing in the big
picture uh at this size.
I would have moved my stop here if this
broke another candlestick lower.
But, you know, there's no point in
moving my stop down. Just It held this
level.
Just let it do its thing now.
You know, maybe
5-minute We made a pullback on a
5-minute, you know, maybe that holds and
we continue lower. I mean, 5-minute
short
big picture
this still has the potential to keep
going lower.
Um it It's literally at an inflection
point right now. It could go either
direction. Um if it goes up, I lose
nothing. If it goes down, I make a
boatload of money. And so, technically
that's I would love to be in that spot
every time.
Literally still could go either
direction, but it really
I I I'm definitely leaning towards up
now. I mean, that's a nice pullback and
a
failed to to go lower. Nasdaq looks
exact same.
Nasdaq actually looks kind of good.
The Nasdaq actually made a new high and
it looks like it's failing.
What a rollercoaster of a trade. We're
still in this chop range. Like
but
I think the longer it stays in this chop
range, the better the short looks.
But, I mean, if we're just going to chop
here, I'm going to lose my mind.
Well, while we wait for this,
uh
if you haven't got it, this platform is
called NinjaTrader. I love using it.
Well, okay. There it is. Out of the
trade.
Again, I'm I'm totally happy with the
trade. Uh
It sucked that it kind of
rollercoastered me there for a while,
but
you know, I think if this is going to go
up, that's the signal.
Um bummer that it it got up nice amount
and got really close
to really getting up a large amount, but
that's trading.